we have 123 definitions of life and some
people are saying we don't have any
definition we only have descriptions of
life and and that's true and that's true
so think about it for two minutes we are
looking for something we don't know it
is but we have a few clues about the
nature of life there are some really
good theories the first one was
Schrodinger right uh in the 40s right
now there is a guy named Jeremy England
it's another biophysical theory of life
it says life is the inevitable resolve
of thermophysics
this is the best way to beat entropy to
fight entropy but when you look at what
we are doing if you want to know what
the nature of life is look at our
languages and they can be very different
languages but they all have the same
purpose right exchange information
understand you know store information
and and uh also whether it is with
somebody at the outside
or thought in yourself
the same thing the cell was doing but
now when you're looking at life and at
the structure of our languages
life started with anestheim so it's an
atom they got together to create
inorganic molecules then you have
complex inorganic molecules then you get
to organic molecules complex in organic
molecules and then you have RNA DNA Etc
look at the structure of our language
we created alphabets
letters
that's your anthem
then we put them together to create
syllables right those syllables get
together to create words
words tell you something
but they are nothing without a verb that
gives the direction that's RNA and DNA
and and then you can put all the
compliments you want our languages are
built exactly as life is built we are
repeating patterns I call this the
mandelbrot universe and the fractal
Universe because this is exactly what it
is uh I I would say that as much as I do
believe to sending probes to explore the
Universe I say we should also look
inward to find the the uh the answer to
some of the profound question of who we
are what's life what's the nature of
life because we are expressing life it
was searching not for life
but for the nature of Life the nature of
absolutely I am more interested in that
because the day we understand the nature
of life then we have a universal by your
signature and it doesn't matter whether
this life responds to the same kind of
biochemical processes as we do although
it makes sense I I told you about the
generational aspect of the bricks of
Life the stuff we are made of the sun is
part of the youngest generation of stars
and the first two generations of stars
didn't produce the kind of elements we
are made of they were stars that were
either
uh without metal just made of allium and
hydrogen or poor in metals
so the stars died off
and stars like the sun were born from
those and this is why we have elements
like carbon hydrogen oxygen that is run
now
and and that's the life we're built on
so I I think it's not stupid to be
looking for something that looks like us
because right now in the universe this
is the stuff that's the most abundant
and we see with the exoplanet with
Kepler with tests and and now with gem
swipe we see that there are many many
different type of planets that may be
habitable in the habitable zone of their
stars there are countless stars like the
Sun but more interestingly enough there
are other type of stars where you do
have habitable zone as well and where
the duration of the Stars
sometimes a thousand times more than our
sun
so you can imagine all sorts of things
and you can imagine what type of life
would be on around those Stars uh the
biochemistry might be quite similar in
fact and especially for the simple life
because Simple Life Starts really
quickly on Earth so my take on this is
that the universe is full of
cyanobacteria but as far as intelligent
life it takes more time